hey everyone dogan here and this is a
quick tutorial about the pronunciation
of this word it was good so in a recent
video i talked about how native english
speakers have the tendency to say
and hakobu as assobu and hakobu with
accents right in the middle because it's
easier as native english speakers we
kind of unconsciously assume that
because other words in japanese have
those pitch accent patterns those pitch
accent patterns that we can easily pick
up on we assume that these these words
play by those rules as well
and that's incorrect and something
similar happens for again this word it
was good as native english speakers we
have no trouble picking up on the pitch
accent pattern picking up on and also
reproducing the pitch accent pattern in
i understand which is
you've probably heard that hundreds of
times right
but the thing is once because we don't
have any trouble picking up on this and
because we often hear it a lot when we
begin our japanese studies we sort of
unconsciously start mapping that pattern
onto onto other common words and a good
example of this is again this word it
was good a lot of native english
speakers when they're starting to study
japanese i did this for the first two
years that i was studying japanese i
said this word with the same pitch
accent pattern as
wakatta so i would say this word it was
good as
yokatta but this is incorrect the
correct pitch accent pattern for this
word is
high low low so
and i'll put in some native recordings
here
yokatta
most japanese learners once they get to
the intermediate and advanced level they
start to finally pick up on the actual
pitch accent pattern of this word and
even if they're not explicitly taught
the pitch accent pattern of the word
they eventually pick up on it but
because there are so many people that
say it with the wrong pitch accent
pattern for so long and again i was one
of these people i just wanted to create
this tutorial such that a lot of people
could stop this bad habit from
developing in the first place again if
you're a native english speaker there's
a high probability that you're saying
the word it was good as yokata but the
correct pitch accent pattern is actually
yokatta
one more native recording
okay guys hope that was useful see you
all again soon
you